hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
august 25th 2021 what's going on how
are you how's it going
how's it going everybody i hope you had
a wonderful football weekend
i did i had a great time i rented that
ufc thing but i [__] was so tired i
fell asleep i know what happened
i'm gonna watch it um i just haven't
seen it yet
um you know kids wear me out man i can't
i'm not gonna lie to you
kids wear me up like i had to watch the
playoff games playoffs
i had to watch them like i was recording
them
and then i would go play with my
daughter up until her nap and then
her nap would happen then i would watch
some more fast forwarding through
commercials
and then [__] go back out to the
driveway it's all about you got to wear
them out
you got to wear them out you know i
played pokemon
i played [__] well i don't play
t-ball anymore i underhand it she
[__] crushes it left-handed
we were on the balance bike
um play this game where i roll the
basketball
down the hill and she tries to beat it
on her scooter
doesn't like to wear the helmet i'm a
kid from the 70s and 80s i respect that
but you know i still got to make sure
she wears the helmet
uh she doesn't like it so i like that
old-school nhl player so
i was doing that while i was watching
the game i was able to watch
most of uh the green bay uh
tampa game i missed the halftime when
they let up that
touchdown pass to tom brady and the
tampa bay buccaneers first of all you
just got to say
what a pleasure that was as a fan to
watch aaron rodgers versus tom brady
when they both had great teams um
i know green bay packer fans got to be
upset losing that
they definitely had the opportunities
because tom started turning it over
through three picks
um in the second half something you
don't you just don't see was one of them
in the first half i can't remember i
think all three were in the second half
and i was like oh [__] because i thought
when they when they lit up that
touchdown
right before the half and then the
second half started they had that fumble
and tom put it in it was like 28 to 10 i
was like oh man
it's [__] over i was like this game
is [__] over and then all of a sudden
green bay just started coming back
and uh you got it what about aaron
rodgers what about when it was third and
15 the guy's in his own [__] endzone
you know running for his life cool as a
cucumber throws a [__] rope 20 25
yards for a first down i mean the guy is
just a beast
um but tampa's defense stepped up and
was able to stop him
on those turnovers i think they turned
all those three picks into like six
points maybe
if that i don't even know um
but it's just [__] unreal unreal tom
is back for his 10th
[__] super bowl it's incredible he's
got his work cut out with him though the
juggernaut kansas city chiefs are coming
his way
um i i mean i don't know
he beat drew brees and the saints and
aaron rodgers and the packers can he
beat patrick mahomes and the [__]
kansas city chiefs
uh i don't know i have no idea
that was really weird that quote though
did you see that quote that uh what the
[__] his name there
bruce aaron said tom brady gets to do
things down here he couldn't do up in
new england like i let him coach the
game you know he couldn't do that up
sometimes i'm just standing there
watching we'll keep doing that bruce
cause it's [__] working
and uh say what you want but i think we
like it when bill belichick calls the
[__] game it worked out pretty good
for us
what the [__] kind of rex ryan horseshit
was that that must have been taken out
of context
cause i like that guy all right and i'm
not even talking as a coach i just look
at that guy
and i say you know what that guy looks
like he owns a boat
and he would invite you over and you'd
say all right bruce what do i need do
you wanna bring some steaks what do you
want some food some booze
and he'd be like don't [__] worry
about just show up and he'd be a great
host
great host [__] said they didn't do
that up and yeah oh boo hoo we didn't do
that up in new england yeah he won six
[__] super bowls and went to nine
okay [__] bill belichick has more
[__] super bowl rings
then you got tango hats [__]
show some respect
i thought he was better than that rex
ryan comment it was probably taken out
of context
you know speaking of which
my buddy told me goes you know there's
this documentary out about about this
sports superstar you made the
documentary
and they showed me a clip they put my
joke in there and they took out all the
[__] punch lines
and then they applied the punchline i
was saying his wife was a gold-digging
[__]
not the floozy he was with and they
[__] changed that too
it's not what i said it's not what i
said
um so maybe maybe bruce meant something
else i don't know what
but um anyway kansas city just uh
they just handled the bills i mean i
know the bills came out early
and uh they were winning but like i
just worried they did not have the
running game
you like whoever's gonna beat the kansas
city chiefs is
going to have to basically do the old
bill belichick thing where it's just
like all right
we're going to take something away from
you and then we're going to control the
clock
and uh if you don't have a [__] solid
running game and you're just gonna try
to go
you know i don't know
pass for pass with kansas city i think
enough teams have showed at this point
that it doesn't work that's what kills
me about the browns
was they were so built i would love to
see belichick coaching that team last
week
that would have been something um yeah
if anybody's going to beat kansas city i
i i feel like
one of their running backs has to have
150 160 yards
you got to have the ball for like 38
minutes and i know that's asking a lot
but jesus christ
i mean tyreek hill is just [__]
ridiculous i mean did you see like when
when he that that last long catch that
he had
it was like everybody forgot how to
tackle they were just like they have so
much respect for his speed they give him
that cushion and then the respect you
gave him
now you're [__] and you got to run
like 40 yards and hope somebody i don't
know
slows them down in front of them i have
no [__] idea but they
they look like juggernauts man um
but i you know tom brady won his first
super bowl against the juggernaut
the greatest show on turf so we'll see
what happens we will see
what happens but i would just have to
say
you know you got to think the chiefs
obviously are going to be the the uh
the favorites and look at the [__]
chiefs man they didn't want a goddamn
[__] thing
in 50 years now they could go back to
back and go from having
one super bowl that nobody even
remembers to all of a sudden
they could they could have three and
then there they are they're almost in
the elite i think you need four what do
you guys think i think you need four
super bowls
up there with the giants right
and then you have the ultra elite where
you got the [__] no then the next
level is five
which is the what the cowboys the 49ers
and then six is the steelers and the
patriots
so i think you need four you really need
five you need five to be
i think up there with everybody else but
whatever they are
they are built but i'm calling it right
now calling it right now the team that
beats kansas city
that beats kansas city it's gonna have
to do that belichick thing they just
double
tyreek hill if that's [__] possible
and go all right beat us with kelsey
underneath at least this guy isn't gonna
make
[__] 60 yard runs
and then you you you got to get a couple
of stops and then you got to eat up the
[__] clock
if i was playing against those guys i
would not snap the ball
just talking to a buddy of mine like
that i would eat up that 25 seconds
every [__] time you want patrick
mahomes
sitting on the [__] sidelines
you know like uh like like bernie uh
[__] sanders at the uh the the
inauguration
which i don't know why that was such a
funny picture to everybody
wasn't that hilarious yeah the guy that
we all wanted
who they boxed out for the second
[__] election
same [__] time and now we're gonna
have this [__] warmonger egg great
that's great that's hilarious let's make
funny memes out of it and ignore that
the [__] democratic
party doesn't give you the guy that you
[__] asked for all right that's
another [__] argument that's
in over my head let's just keep going
here let's keep going here so
um
let's see here uh what did i want to
talk about oh my god if [__] patrick
mahomes underhands the ball for a
touchdown
one more [__] time and i have to
listen to people in the broadcast
booth lose their [__] mind like they
haven't seen him do it 50 [__] time
oh my god you [__] believe that
i mean they got so many new little cute
plays around the goal line
we get it like
am i the only person the first time they
did that was ah that's a little sneaky
play
i wasn't freaking out
like they just reinvent that is
basically
quarterbacks do that all the time they
just do it backwards to a running back
he's doing it forward he's essentially
throwing a football
about three feet to a professional
athlete the same way i throw it to my
daughter
i'm working on overhand with her all
right
i mean that is incredible that's like a
lateral except it went forwards
i get it i get it there's 9 000 channels
so now you gotta act like everything is
just [__]
the most insane thing you'd ever seen in
your [__] life
um i will tell you why i do think uh kc
is beatable because when they came out
uh after halftime
and they said to andy reid what'd you
tell your team and he said score more
points
uh i don't know maybe the game has
changed so much but to me i always think
oh that means you're [__] beatable
that means you don't believe
in your [__] defense right
isn't that what the [__] that means i
don't know i don't know back in the day
if
during the regular season you're always
scoring 30 35 points while giving up 25
[__] points a game
or whatever 2025 those teams always
[__] lost by the third round
or the afc or nfc championship game just
saw that time and again but i think it's
changed so much
um like the rules i'll take a couple of
[__] things that bugged me
brady threw one up for grabs over the
middle
all right and the safety's right there
ready to pick it off
and then that number 14 comes in at the
last second
and just bumps into the safety bumps
them off the ball and catches
and catches it okay that's
textbook offensive pass interference but
they got this thing that the wide
receiver has the [__] right to be
there
if the safety does that every everybody
in the [__]
field is throwing a flag and then the
other one the helmet to helmet like
if a running back has the [__] ball
or receiver and they
lower their [__] head down to their
waist what is the defensive player
supposed to do
the game moves so goddamn fast you're
coming in with your shoulder
you're gonna hit him in the waist and at
the last second he brings his [__]
head down what are you supposed to do at
that point
um those are the only ones like i don't
like and i know that there was that
brutal past interference
time for a pass interference call at the
end of the green bay game
and i got a hit i thought that game was
officiated great
and it's just when you're grabbing onto
a jersey and the guy's three yards away
and you still have his jersey
and he looks like [__] stretch
armstrong from back in the day
i mean they have to call that i would
think so um
you know watching it at full speed i
thought it was like oh man why would
they call that them but then when they
had that one really good angle
where you saw what the back judge saw
it's like all right
can't get mad at that so anyways there
you go
you got tom brady versus tom brady jr
um
um what the [__] am i trying to say here
[__] brain is so goddamn uh showdown
showing off i kept thinking the showdown
facing off there we go in the [__]
super bowl who do
you like i obviously want tom brady
i mean tampa to win this gate it's great
seeing gronk get a big catch too
um every [__] new england fan i know
is going [__] crazy right now because
tom brady is in the super bowl we have
it's like my my buddy texts me goes dude
that felt like a patriots win
i'm so [__] rooting for the guy so i
i think that's really cool
then as much as that guy left
everybody's not being a [__] about it
i'm sure you could find a couple of
[__] but everybody's
is very in new england as far as my
contacts are all very happy
and are rooting for him to uh to win but
on the other side i also like
you know no who's there is no other side
i'm rooting for tom brady
but like i always like the chiefs anyway
so it's great seeing them
you know back trying to be the first
team to go back to back
since the 0304 patriots tom brady can
stop it oh my god there's so many
different angles here
he could get number seven number
[__] seven
how crazy is that you know
and i was a little offended that they
lumped them in with peyton manning and
craig morton
and kurt warner well i can't get mad at
kurt warner
you know what i just wanted tom brady to
be the first guy to go back with a
different [__] team
um but evidently he didn't that's what i
was really upset with when they brought
up that stat
he's doing what these three other guys
already did it's like
[__] so all right enough
enough with my fan boying here um
but that first game i really liked and
uh buffalo bills
nothing to hang your heads about what a
season you guys had and you were
definitely the future of the afc east i
hope you go further than that
and how great was it that you got a
51-yard field goal
during a playoff you know i feel [__]
bad for those guys
they have to win the [__] super bowl
because if they don't
they're just gonna keep showing the
[__] those four
that you lost they just won't let you up
off the mat as a [__] red
sox fan i know what that feels like they
showed that [__] bucky den
and [__] bill buckner and all of this
[__]
forever and ever and ever and ever and
ever and ever they just showed it for
[__] ever and we had to win like
three of them
before they stop showing it um
i remember that even when we we [__]
finally won it
then we we weren't doing we had some
injuries the next year in september i
remember dan shaughnessy going is the
curse back it was just like oh my god
dude
[__] move forward um
all right all right with that with that
let's talk about some other [__] i've
been uh
i went out and i flew yesterday it was
raining out it was really
amazing man it was raining out and we
were doing auto rotations and everything
and uh we were hanging around the
weather kept getting worse and worse and
worse
and uh but it was fun and then all of a
sudden the guy goes
uh hey man this is the last one you can
do because then we're going ifr
helicopters aren't allowed to fly in ifr
but it wasn't a big deal because we're
at the airport and
worst-case scenario we just set it down
there taken uber back to uh
the other airport so
you know the other airport unfortunately
was just like one puddle jump over
and we were able to fly over there and
as we went over there um
right as we landed they were going to
ifr we could still see but it was like
i never flown in stuff like that and was
obviously with an instructor and
everything
and it was really really great
experience
despite the fact that i would never fly
in that by myself
but um i got all this really really cool
experience
and i would show you guys the video of
me doing auto rotations but i just know
that all you guys are just gonna say
dude you're gonna [__] die and i just
you know what i mean this is
it's like if you have a motorcycle you
can only show the video to another
friend who has a motorcycle
but if you try i've kind of learned
that if you [__] like
try and um
i don't know talk to people who don't
fly that's
all they do all they do is just predict
that you're you're going to [__]
crash
it's just like why why the [__] are you
doing that man i'm having a good time
i'm enjoying my [__] hobby
um this is how much i'm having a good
time i went over just to pre-flight
just a pre-flight just to do it again
because i'm flying the cadbury which is
a new one for me
and i just want to know where everything
is
and uh what all this stuff is and um
i don't know i was just going over there
just hanging out doing that and then my
instructor swung by he's like it's not
that bad
let's go and go fly so the big thing
that i've been learning for my
auto rotations is we've been doing quick
stops
uh and once i get that under control
that's like basically a quick stop is
essentially the same
uh inputs as the end of an auto rotation
so we just did a bunch of those and then
i started doing autos we were doing 180
autos
we were doing uh over the spot my
favorite thing
and i was just like let me just take
this one
so we were like right over the spot i
bled off all my
forward air speed we started to just we
know we're descending the whole time but
started descending a little more rapidly
actually you're able to go backwards in
the helicopter and then nose it down
once you you know judge your speed and
everything like that
and i was actually i put one like right
on the just beyond the number
uh of the runway which is the goal where
we were trying to stop
and where we trying to land and i had my
best one as far as like when i was
pulling the collective up and and the
right foot
uh pedal input my nose didn't go flying
off to one side or the other i didn't
over correct with the right pedal
and i didn't pull too much power pulling
the nose to the left either
i was pretty much i think i was just a
little to the right and i was able to
back off a little with the right pedal
um because that's the thing at the end
of the auto rotation you don't want to
be
you want to bleed off all your forward
air speed and then you want to be
faced straight ahead because you know if
you had just a little bit just a little
bit and if you landed just a little
sideways you could roll it
which you wouldn't die but you'd ruin
your helicopter so why the [__] would
you want to do that you know
um so anyway i did a bunch of those
and just had the best time
and where i'm flying out of now is is uh
it's a decent ride away from where i
live but i'm able to listen to a french
lesson
on the way there on and on the way back
i'm sticking with that
pimsleur french and uh it's really
helping with my pronunciation and all
that type of [__] and i know how to say
all of this stuff now
but i don't know how to have a
conversation because i'm not talking
with anybody so that's
the next thing i need and somebody was
telling me that
who knows all these languages and [__]
going like you know they got this thing
you can just sign up and you can talk to
people in other
countries knowing you know
that you know trying to learn your
language you're trying to learn their
language or whatever you can [__] go
in there and like it's video they're
like yeah i'm like that's
that's too [__] weird that's too
weird something about that just
feels like a dating app i'm a married
guy
it's like i am not [__] going there
i'll find uh
i'll find somebody out here that [__]
speaks french and i'll shoot the [__]
with them
i'll figure it out that way i think i
think that's a better way to go about it
so
anyway um
yeah the super bowl once again tom brady
is going in there
like he did when he was a young man and
he's playing a team
like his first team that is a offensive
juggernaut
that i think everybody if you you know
if he wasn't tom brady is going to be
picking kansas city
and um and i just
i just oh man mahomes is just he has he
just has
it he has that guy has that
[__] thing beyond just being [__]
amazing
is he just has like that
i don't know what it is he's got that
extra [__] thing
as does tom so we shall see i think
tampa has a better it's weird tampa i
think has a better defense
but not much better but kansas city has
a better offense and
they have the best offense in the league
so i think that right there makes tampa
an underdog but um i don't know i think
tom's been an underdog the last couple
of weeks so
we shall see this is why they play the
game
that's why they [__] play the games
all right
with that this podcast is always from
here on out will be brought to you by
herb cider
tim herb alexander has an absolutely
delicious
hard cider you can go to uh
herbscider.com
it's perfect for the winter months um
that we're in right now it's great to
watch the super bowl so why don't you
order some
you know have a little something
different for your super bowl party at
and herbsider.com else do we got here um
the [__] do i got it oh jesus christ
dude i've been smoking cigars like a
[__] lunatic
because my daughter wants me to quit so
i was just like all right well i'm not
throwing out these cigars i'll just
finish all the cigars
in my uh humidor which is giving me the
green [__] light
to just [__] smoke every afternoon
when nobody's around
and i gotta tell you if those things
wouldn't kill you i would i would never
stop
i would never stop so what's gonna
happen is i'm just not gonna smoke at
home anymore which really makes me sad
but i know it's
doing it for the kids so i will only
smoke if i'm on the road
or if i'm locally here and a friend
wants to go out to a cigar bar whenever
the [__] you can do that again
we shall figure we'll figure that out um
i don't know people are getting the
vaccine i haven't heard anybody die
or [__] start eating somebody else's
face it seems
like uh i know it's early
but you know i don't know dodger stadium
everybody was over there two and a half
hour [__] weight
had a buddy of mine went over there and
got it thank god
um oh and i've been sort of avoiding
this i got
i got some more sad news um david
richardson
uh passed away um
i don't even know where to begin about
what a legend this guy was
um david richardson is
just one of the top he was there from
day one with efforts for family in the
writers room he had the funniest
darkest craziest
creative mind in the room i thought like
just the stuff
so much of what f is for family is is
because of his talent
he was the one that um
he was the one that made frank a
republican
and and defend nixon and make fun of the
kennedys
and which was something that i never
would have thought to do
and it made this great back and forth
between
the character of kevin played by the
great justin long
um you know who's an artist
he plays guitar and he smokes weed it
just it just added that
extra like conflict and
um i don't know and some of the [__] oh
my god so much of the [__] that he said
in the writers room that we couldn't
even he couldn't even do on the show
just to entertain us um
i talked about this a little bit on the
billbert podcast
uh i remember when prince died and
everyone was just oh my god i can't
believe prince died
and he came and goes yeah i think he's
overrated and just started this big
[__] argument just for the fun of it
and we all took the bait and he was a
big allman brothers fan
and was talking about dwayne allman and
he just took on the whole [__]
writer's
room and he had a [__] ball doing it
big [__] eating grin and we all knew
what he would
what what he was doing and we just had
so much fun we had so much fun with him
and uh
he was 65 i'm 52 so he was that age
where he was like
this cool older brother and this father
figure and
i got a chance to spend a lot of time
with him outside of the show
you know we went golfing one time we
were always trying to go golf and i just
never had time but
we did get that in one time and um
he came out to a couple of my shows
when i was in vegas he came out to a
bunch when i was here in la
and what i loved about him is i always
felt
how proud he was of whatever new thing
that i was working on that he really
rooted for me
and i also felt that we just really
connected
comedically uh i am absolutely stunned
that he's gone and um
i don't know man like i said remember a
few weeks ago when i i said i went i got
i went to that pizza place and there was
that
that kid there working there she's
probably in her 20s whatever that's a
kid to me
she said uh she had a hoodie on that
said
[__] live forever
and i just was that was such a profound
statement from
as far as where i'm sitting in life
where it just seems like
my greatest friends and the nicest
people i've ever met i don't know why
i don't know why in the last 15 years i
can't tell you how many of them i've
lost
um i'm [__] sick of it but i've
realized that this is part of the
part of the journey of living is that as
you get older people you know are going
to die so
enjoy the hell out of them while they're
still here
and pray to whatever you pray to that
there's something after this so you can
see him again
so who knows who knows what's going on
so to the great david richardson thank
you so much
it was an absolute honor and a pleasure
to work with you
you know to be get a friendship outside
of the business
and hear all your incredible this was a
guy who was in the business for 40 years
like
he broke into the business he used to
submit jokes to the show he ha
back in the late 70s and he worked on
everything from massive hits to big
flops
and he had all these hilarious
everything from like malcolm in the
middle
and um he worked on that show i just
forgot the name of it with
uh charlie sheen and jonathan cryer
worked on our show obviously wrote
movies
um and if there's one thing i learned
in my five seasons at f is for family is
the how hard people work in the writers
room
and the editors the people that draw all
of those people that for some reason
when they give out the [__] awards
like
like those people they they do it like
between commercial breaks so there's
like a pre
tape it's really wrong because um
i'll tell you one of the things that
made my drinking go off the [__]
rails and i finally had to quit
was sitting in a writer's room 12 hours
a day and i remember when i quit
drinking
you know david was sober too
and he used to talk about he goes you
know
because he has two uh younger boys from
his second marriage he used to say when
they get older
you know and they're out of the house
and you know being a great dad and blah
blah he goes i i he goes i don't know
i think i'm just going to have one cold
miller high life and i just we should
just sit there thinking about that how
great would that taste right now
but we both knew because we were old
dads that we couldn't do it so there was
another level that i bonded with him on
and
um i love him to death
and i am going to [__]
miss him like crazy i said loving the
death and he's dead
[__] sucks i [__] hate this [__] i
swear to god
you know i swear to god i i
i don't even i don't understand what the
[__] purpose of life is
when [__] like this keeps happening you
know
uh thank god i got kids cause i swear to
god i would just be like so so that's
just [__] it i mean
what is the point maybe these [__]
people that just
party and die maybe that's the way to do
it like it makes you think [__] like
that i know this is [__] dark and all
that crap but
um it is what it is but uh absolute
absolute [__] legend david richardson
and i cannot
tell you how many times that guy had me
crying laughing
in the writer's room when he would just
say some crazy
sh and what was you know what was great
was i existed in between
where he was and the younger people in
the room
where they grew up in a much just a much
different time as far as
like political correctness and all these
new terms
and uh he would just say [__] or i would
say [__] knowing
you're not supposed to say it and that
he would laugh and other people would be
like what the [__] you know
it was just so much fun man it's so much
fun so
uh all right that's it that's it rest in
peace david richardson man
you were the best buddy you were the
best all right
let me see here uh all right we got
vyom is that how you say it
pronounced vi ohm like biome the vi
is pronounced v y as in steve vi
viom all right i got it viomas
that's what they have to do they gotta
like [__] spell it eight different
ways and then bring a
guitar hero from my childhood biome
helps you take control of your health so
you can improve your energy
gut health and boost your immune system
health
uh how does it work number one uh
test what what are your body cells
actually doing
number two it gives you complete new
complete nutrition plan and creates your
custom
supplement number three i.e bill's
personal one a day vitam
vitamin oh after they analyze all that
you get your own vitamin
with only the ingredients that i would
need
at my specific doses based on my test
cut out all the [__] that i don't need
that could be hurting me
it's the perfect supplement which is
amazing i guess they're gonna when they
now you gotta hand it to these
scientists man i mean you [__] an
envelope you sent it to them the stuff
that they know about you
it's like [__] hannibal lecter uh
sorry uh vyomi
biome biome has partnered with the mayo
clinic
united health and kaiser and is used by
olympic gold
medalists and elite professional
athletes okay so it's not just just
a podcaster they got olympic gold
medalist and elite professional athletes
uh did you say just throw the ball
forward how fun to have
uh vyomi uh viom will tell you how
specific foods affect you you may be
eating too much or not enough of what
your body needs
biomes phone application lets you get
these answers on demand
question about food just check the app i
keep saying i'm going to [__] do this
i have to do this because this seems
like the easiest way to stay in shape
go to vyom.com viome.com to get your
unique insights
for better health and wellness use the
promo code burr to save 55
on your first planned purchase this is
the best discount anywhere
uh special for bill okay there you go
get into the shape of your life without
having to blow out your joints in a
[__] elliptical
when you can actually see what foods you
can put together that's going to help
you out
all right simply save you know everyone
wants to keep their home
and family safe whether it's from a
break-in
a fire flooding or a medical emergency
simply safe home security delivers
award-winning
24 7 protection with simply safe
you don't get an arsenal of cameras and
sensors you get the best professional
monitors in the business
they got you back day and night ready to
send police fire
or emts when you need them uh
most straight to your door simply safe
has an arsenal of sensors and cameras
that protect every inch of your home
you can set it up yourself in about 30
minutes it's super easy
then simply says professionals take over
monitoring your home 24 7 and ready to
send help the moment
there's an alarm plus with simply safe
there's no long-term contact
contract sorry no hidden fees or
installation costs right now
my listeners get a free home security
camera when you purchase a simply safe
system
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e dot com slash bar
simply safe.com you also get a 60-day
risk-free trial so there's nothing to
lose
who the hell's going to give it back
after 60 days
why the [__] would you do that nobody
broke it in my house i don't even use a
[__] thing
visit simplysafe.com for your free
security camera today that's simply
safe.com
burr all right duke
cannon this is somebody new uh while a
robust beard is the preferred look
of many a hard-working man do
hard-working men even have beards
anymore i feel like it's
hipsters who want to look like they work
hard or at least work with their hands
you know for some reason you got to grow
like a [__] lumberjack beard to make
artisan ice cream
a fellow should never have to work too
hard on maintaining the beard itself
duke cannon beard goods are effective
yet
uncomplicated so you can spend your free
time
fishing rather than following a 14-step
grooming routine
take best damn beard wash it's lather
not only good not only conditions your
whiskers
but moisturizes the skin underneath you
know for you guys we have those big bird
nest ones this stuff is great
so to look nice and you even go and uh
if you ever go insane wait sort of look
nice if you ever go insane and decide to
shave
oh yeah and underneath is all red and
patchy you don't want that
or best damn beard bomb which protects
your beard with a pleasant
woodsy fragrance like a redwood forest
on your face
aquaman doesn't smell like an ice cream
parlor and
last by very but very much not least
new bush beard oil made with organic
natural oils and just a touch of bush
beer
uh to tame and strengthen it'll have all
your whiskers smelling like a deep
whiff of bright mountain air
i love how because you have a beard
everybody thinks you're an outdoorsman
you know what i mean anybody who's a
real outdoorsman is never going to hear
this ad we're all living inside
shouldn't smell like a freshly cleaned
kitchen floor um so simply simplify your
beard routine with seriously effective
duke cannon beard wash
bomb and oil conveniently available uh
on dukecanyon.com this is not
canon.com i'm gonna get this [__] uh at
your local target cause every once in a
while oh freckles gets a little red
patch on the right side of my beard a
little dry skin in there
uh pick some up next time you're out at
two
to three times larger than the
competition's products
what pick some up next time you're out
at two to three times larger than the
competition's products
it'll be a while before you have to
restock oh
see things are getting easier already
sorry beard cannon duke cannon i could
have [__]
read that a lot better all right here we
go let's get into what you guys think
here for
the week all right over baked birthday
cake tip oh by the way thank you to
everybody who watched the uh hot boxing
with mike tyson
uh on that podcast i got to do a podcast
with mike tyson and jeremy piven
um [__] incredible time i still can't
believe
i got to meet that guy twice in my life
i think i've made i've met the best that
ever did it
uh uh lawrence taylor and i met
uh and mike tyson lawrence taylor mike
tyson i'm trying to think about anybody
else
i think that's it i never met richard
pryor all right
over baked birthday cake tip aloha
billy bolo head hawaiian
pigeon word for bald head oh cool aloha
billy
bolo head okay i used to do gigs in
hawaii before this [__] happened
i'll listen for that hey you [__]
mahala you
bolo head is that what you say i was
listening to your podcast on january
21st 2021
um in regard to your overbaking your
daughter's birthday cake
yeah what i should have done when they
said it was like you know whatever 30 to
35 minutes i should have come in there
at 25
is what i should have done and checked
it but i didn't i was
fighting off a cold all right i am a
professional
baker and pastry cook from hawaii with
13 years experience oh please give me
your sage advice
if you've ever accidentally over baked a
cake in the future you can always cut
the cake in half horizontally
with a serrated bread knife and apply
and soak simple syrup on the tops of
each
to moisten it before you ice it no way
you can watch video tutorials on how to
do it if you really enjoy baking i
highly recommend the book the art of
french pastry i'm in
anyway mahalo mahala is that how you say
it mahala
was it mahalo mahala get low get low but
hello
uh for the laughs and i can't wait for
next season of efforts for family
aloha to you and your family oh isn't
that nice of you
susie the uh the pastry chef i'm gonna
check that out
who would have thought simple syrup all
right
emotional boyfriend or amaya [__]
i love when the ladies write in dear
billy bagpipes
i love the bagpipes i know a lot of
people hate them i love the bagpipes
um i don't like how they get treated
like a kazoo
uh or is a bagpipe just a difficult
kazoo
um i've been with my boyfriend for two
years now and it's going pretty good
i don't know how you talk so maybe
that's just how you talk but that's kind
of funny if you're with somebody for two
years and it's going pretty good don't
you want to be going great
i think it was going to go great it
would have been going great by now um
anyways
maybe you just saw your time yeah it's
going pretty good uh we have some
we have the same hobbies humor goals
communication
wait an interest the problem is
however is our emotional communication
meaning
he's a complete nancy boy that makes me
some sort of a gi jane i guess oh and
that makes me some sort of a gi jain i
guess
although i don't know you personally i
feel we communicate similarly
uh i talk a lot of [__] say [__] you
casually
tell it like i see it no jesus no matter
somebody's feelings whenever somebody
says i say how it is i always think like
all right that means you're
you're being an [__] i tell that how
it is
that's how racists like to say that
uh all right i know what you're saying
though okay i tell it like it is no
matter
someone's feelings uh was taught crying
is a signal
for weakness he cries all the time
constantly over over explains his
thought
his happy-go-lucky even at six a.m and
is the type to wake me up
whispering how beautiful i am i have to
choke back my laughter
when that last one happens
jesus christ okay
i i love him dearly but the majority oh
so you actually
it's going great but you're so walled
off emotionally earlier you said it's
going pretty good all right i'm starting
to understand you
um i love him dearly but the majority of
our fights
stems from my attitude in quotes not
taking any
responsibility for that okay my attitude
and it becomes unbearable for us both
uh i personally like my coldness because
i feel
it's made me a stronger woman and has
led me not to victimize myself
um i would be a liar if i didn't admit
that i would like to tap into my
emotional side a bit more
i've even shown him clips of you and nia
talking saying see
she doesn't get mad at him forehead wait
i've even shown him clips of you and nia
talking saying see she doesn't get mad
at him for having an attitude
and he replies with yeah well he's
actually funny
i'm not a seasoned comedian and my tone
isn't paired with the silly boston
accent
so i'm [__] out of luck well i would
think the fact that you say nancy boy
you probably got some good
english accent going on uh sometimes i
feel like i should go and find someone
who understands my
tones better and therefore i wouldn't
have to try anymore exactly sometimes
you get sick and you don't want to
[__]
you get sick of it you don't want to be
challenged but then again i've dated
guys more similar to me and it was
boring
not having the challenge of seeing
someone so different
have you ever had this this same dilemma
and do you have any advice
on either being more soft or at least
delivering your harsh words in a
charming way
compliments compliments compliments
thanks and go [__] yourself um
yeah i've been where you're at i'm a
little further down your road um
listen um
i think you love this guy you're not
gonna leave this guy
and he's just you know when you're in a
really good relationship the other
person
is going to challenge you so
i think that
the fact that he wakes up and tells you
how beautiful you are the fact that
you're laughing
i get it because you're like we talk
about i got morning breath my hair's all
over the place
and you want to laugh i think wanting to
laugh in moments like that speaking
personally is
part of your childhood your [__] up
childhood that made you
the person that you are and i've said
the exact same thing
if i didn't have the childhood that i
had i don't think i would be able to
you know handle the [__] on the job
that i picked
which is just a job i put this is the
job i picked it's a [__] job you show
up on time you do your [__] job
you get paid you say thank you when you
leave that's what it is anything else is
just a [__]
it's it's it's [__] so
being the way you are can really help
you yeah when you go out into the world
cause it is a cold place but the thing
is
is when you come home you gotta shut
that off
because i remember way back in the day
when the seller was the seller and the
table was the table
um my wife could tell
when i went to the cellar and when i
didn't
i'd come home and i was so on busting
balls mode
i'd come home and i and i needed to
leave that at the door
so what you need to do is you need to
you need to come his way
all right so i would work on coming his
way
and then talk to him about [__]
crying at the drop of the hat because
you don't need that either
i mean that's not really reassuring as a
woman
that you know if some guy comes through
the front [__] door
he's at least gonna [__] grab some
sort of blunt object and give it a shot
you don't want him screaming louder than
you
but i would say that you're with this
person this person is going to make you
a better person
um if your life works out the way mine
did and
um i love my wife and
she's funny as [__] hell and can bus
chops with the best of them
but she always lets me know when i go
too far and then i legit feel bad
so i don't know if you're there yet i
mean it took me i mean oh my god
from like [__] my teenage years to
being about 35
before anybody telling me what they
needed
from me emotionally didn't immediately
gross me out or make me have to fight
back laughing
i mean i used to have this thing once
when people would cry
talking to me like i i would burst out
laughing i would i still to this day i
i watch movies and i laugh in the wrong
parts
and that's just part of i don't know
whatever the [__] happened to me
so i think you got a great guy and i
think you know you got a great guy
um so i would come his way but he needs
to cry
less all right i can say that without
even knowing him
all right okay but you also have to
accept him for who he is
all right if he's gonna [__] cry i
mean i don't know i don't know what he
does
for a living i don't know all right
let's move on
talking all this emotional stuff's
making me uncomfortable all right
long-winded girlfriend
uh hi mr beautiful burr all right so
everybody's uh
everybody's talking about this they're
their significant others this week it
seems
except for the wonderful lady that
taught me about the cake thank you so
much
uh me and my girlfriend have been dating
almost five years
we live together have a great dog
together
we used to go to concerts before the
pandemic and have the most fun and
explore
consciousness together ah okay elevated
way of saying
take hallucinogens of course my only
issue is
she tells the longest most uninteresting
stories with five million tangents
and unimportant side characters
all right well yeah
that can happen so i would say
my next question would be how many
stories does she tell a day
anyways i'm not only expected to listen
to these 30-minute soliloquies
but follow every plot point and then
respond at the very end
i often don't know what to say at the
end of a story because they take
so long and involve so many topics
that i get lost and uninterested she
then always tells me i have
conversation issues and i'm not good at
holding them
conversation issues is that even a thing
i figured she just would have thrown out
the hacky add
my question is is this something that
will happen in all relationships no
you're just
dating someone that doesn't know how to
tell a story how do i approach this but
that's weird that you would say this
does this happen in all relationships
i mean i can tell you this if you're
gonna break up with somebody
because they can't tell a [__] story
then i don't think you ever love them
you know my wife tells a great story but
if she's telling a bad one i just start
heckling
i'll just be like stay on target
not important information
this is what i would do if i was you
i would say listen i know
that when you tell a story i don't
listen
and i know that that bothers you okay my
problem is
is your stories are really long and you
just say a lot of stuff that doesn't
need to be in there
you give me the director's cut okay the
256 minute
once upon a time in america all right
like you guys suggested i watched last
week which i'm still trying to find
where i can watch that
um so what i would do is say okay
you're going to help me become a better
listener are you going to do that for me
well that's what i would say that's how
you go into it you just say
okay listen
if you help me with something i'll help
you with something
right and then you just say listen can
you help me become
a better listener because i really want
to be a better better listener when
you're telling your stories
okay because i know how much that
bothers you can you help me with that
and she's a woman and they're giving so
she'll be
you know unless she got somebody ice
cold she's gonna be like absolutely
i'm so happy you asked me that and then
say great
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
help you tell a better story
at that point she's gonna get mad and
just
we're both gonna have little flags
i have a red one you have a blue one
just like politics
all right when you feel i'm not paying
attention you wave your flag and
when i feel you're going off the rails
with this story i'll wave my little flag
okay and i think what you're gonna find
is
you're gonna be waving your flag right
after i start waving mine
you're going to start to learn where you
lose the listener
she's not going to go for this [__] i'm
just trying to be funny anyways he says
my question is
this is something that happened this is
something that happens in all
relationships how do i approach this
have every trying to write time i try to
explain to her to simply
simply try and make the stories more
concise so i can respond to her point
she gets upset
yeah see you're not gonna learn anything
see a lot of broads
they can't take it they cannot
see the thing about women as much as
they're all out there especially the
white women
are out there acting like you know they
they exist in some
slave labor [__] universe the reality
is
is most of them are so [__] coddled
that by the time you get into a
relationship with them
they can't even handle the slightest
of criticism not even the slightest
and then oh so what you're saying is i'm
[__] yeah
that's not what i'm saying sound i'm
saying the big thing is is when they do
that you don't get drawn into a fight
you got to maintain your cool and just
be like listen
you know you give me pointers you try to
help me be a better person i'm just
trying to help you be a better person
now what would happen if every time you
did that to me i just got mad
i would not grow as a person i'm doing
right now what i'm supposed to do in
this relationship we're supposed to help
each other become better people
okay and if i'm the only one listening
to you
then what you're saying is that you're
this complete person
or you're just so much better than me
that you don't need to listen to any of
my critiques
then what the [__] are you doing with me
what are you slumming it
um i try one of the two of those
the flag thing would be my wife would
find that funny
um i don't know what yours is like um
and he goes i don't want to end the
relationship
doing a silly issue sorry i'm yawning
here but i'm also at my wit's end any
advice would be
so helpful uh my best to your whole
family and thanks
uh yeah yeah i do have to tell you man
like how many [__] stories is she
telling
that you and how bad are the stories
that you're actually
considering leaving
she just tells one bad story a [__]
week and it's long as [__] and that's
you're making you think i gotta get the
[__] out of here i would get the [__]
out of there
okay but she's telling one every day and
it's becoming a fight or even every
other day then i guess i get it
um anyway all right oh speaking of flags
girlfriend
and red flags uh
dear ball sack looking ass
and hopefully the lovely nia i'm a 24
year old from the land of
wheat beer and fat girls good old kansas
the jayhawks that's my college
basketball team i've been dating my
girlfriend now for about seven months
with no problems whatsoever
and have talked about moving in
why am i yawning uh about moving her
into my house
when she is done with schooling come
summertime
she's a year younger than me and almost
done with school blah blah blah
anyways there's been no red flags in a
relationship
until recently oh geez yes he writes um
she has recently mentioned in a joking
manner we all know and ain't joking
that she would like to get her boobs
done no red flag there right
um no i mean i think the kardashians
have made that [__] so [__]
mainstream
um anyway well a few weeks go by and she
mentions wanting to get a nose job
along with lip injections and botox in
her forehead
okay yeah see ya bye bye
i was taken by surprise by the amount of
insecurity she truly holds in herself
which is something she has been
she has been open about before this is a
major turn-off to me and seems to be her
trying to chase
temporary happiness she's a very
attractive lady
already in most people's eyes
all right you need to tell her that
she's attractive and lead off the in
most people's eyes
um i would i would
i would oh then he says so here's my
problem ball sack looking ass
now wait a minute are you the one giving
her this comment complex this is the
second time you said i look like a
[__] ball back i'm ready to get
botox halfway through this goddamn
question
um i would suggest
to her i i would just listen i would say
i i would
talk to somebody first for a long time
you're still young and you're still
beautiful
that's not even stills bad thing to say
to someone like that you're young and
beautiful i don't know what's going on
with you
you need to talk to somebody before
you know you start making this is like
you're getting a tattoo on your face
that's what plastic surgery is it's a
[__] tattoo on your face
your eyebrows are gonna be that way
forever your lips are gonna be that way
forever
um i don't know well a few weeks go by
and she mentions wanting to get it okay
she already says
a nose job
so here's my problem ballsack looking
ass
in my eyes she will never be happy and
there will always be something that
isn't good
enough for her and it will drain me in
the long run
i know this seems ladies like he's being
ice cold but this is how you need to be
in a relationship
you got to really weigh what you're into
i mean what what you're what you're in
for
because these [__] things are hard
all right and uh you know
i think it's pretty [__] weird if you
married someone and by your 15th
anniversary
uh people look at your wedding photos
going like i didn't know you were
married before
no that's the same woman anyway she
doesn't seem to think it's a big deal
about getting all of this it would
it would make her feel better about
herself so what's the issue
should i let her do what she wants with
her body and not worry about it
or is this a real concern for me to get
out now
give me your thoughts and hopefully we
can hear from the lovely nia as well
thanks and go [__] yourself i i would
get out now
just the way this whole thing is written
i don't feel like
you love this person
i think uh yeah i don't think you're 24
you're young
i mean you know what that should freak
you out at 24 that someone wants to
change their
[__] face you're young get the [__]
out just get out
i would get out that's exactly what i
would do i would get the [__] out
and if you're gonna stay in i would tell
her to go
talk to somebody for at least a year
a year in therapy to figure out why
when she looks in the mirror she sees
whatever she's seeing
um but this
her issues are not your responsibility
and your issues are not her
responsibility when you guys get in
relationships
your issues are or what's going to come
to the forefront
and it's what you're going gonna have to
deal with and that's where the love has
to come in
because if the love isn't there it's
it's not gonna make it and just the way
you've written this [__] thing i just
feel like it's not there
i could be wrong if it is there um what
i would say and you're going to stay in
this i would suggest that this person
finds out why it i'm guessing she's
you're around your age right
you're younger than you i'm 24 been
dating a girlfriend blah blah blah
well let's say she's your age i mean 24.
shouldn't be getting plastic surgery at
24 you know
what are you doing you're in you in the
prime of your life
you should be this is the beginning part
where you learn
you're undoing all of your childhood and
learning to
accept yourself as an adult
and see what your strengths are what
your weaknesses are and have a sense of
humor about your weaknesses you work on
them and then you go to your strengths
and find somebody fun to share your life
with that's what you should be doing i i
really don't see
um
that's really why you know i don't know
the cultural effect
of that kardashian show
you know where you got like some of them
are like models and they're already it's
like you're a model you're making a
living by being beautiful and you're
already getting work done
before you're 25 it's just that's a hell
of a [__] statement
um that's crazy i don't know it's
[__] nuts
anyway that's just my opinion what the
[__] do i know all right major
girlfriend
red flags okay this is what i just read
right
20 years is this just like all red flags
oh another red flag here
made your girlfriend red flags drama all
right this is the red flag [__]
podcast
the challenge for people throwing the
challenge we're gonna call it from now
on
i love i'm in the relationship with this
guy this woman whatever
and i'm i'm feeling like i gotta throw
uh the challenge flag here
all right all right hey billy bust
inside
bust inside is that because i'm a dad
twice is that what it is uh i have a
situation
on my hands and would like some advice
from you so i am
20 years old and i've been with my girl
now girlfriend now for about four months
but we've known each other for about a
year ever since
starting to date her i've have dealt
with non-stop drama and it's getting to
the point i'm seriously considering
ending this
wait ever since i started dating i've
dealt with non-stop drama yeah these are
easy get out of this you're 20 years old
run free young man and don't get into
another relationship immediately
sit down and process and be signal
single and figure out what the [__] that
was
and how and how you stepped on that land
mine so you don't do it again
anyway he goes this all started when
about a month ago
we started dating she told me she was
going to get flown out by this dude to
celebrate his birthday
what is she a call girl i immediately
told her that's not happening and
freaked out
she told me he's already booked the
ticket for her and that he's just a
friend
go [__] yourself
yeah go listen to bismarcky for this you
don't need me and also
even if he wanted to have sex he
couldn't because of his
religion which i immediately called
[__] on
he's a guy and has a dick all right good
man you're wise be on your years good
for you
i told her if anyone is flying her
anywhere it's me
she then apologized and said i was right
and it wouldn't happen again
[__] she also has basically only all
guy friends
dude get the [__] out of this thing
they're all super shifty saying stuff
like
when are we going to date and i want to
[__] you
i don't care that if you have a
boyfriend
yeah what are you doing buddy now you're
20. this happens
i have talked to her over and over about
this that i don't appreciate that the
other guys talk to her like this
and she does nothing about it but play
it off like it's some sort of
joke but nothing ever changes she never
cuts them off yeah
yeah dude if she hasn't already [__]
all of those guys just get out now
before you you leave with an std
uh the last straw came tonight when she
told me that one of the guys said he's
going to fly her
show her up and fly here oh sorry
show up and [__] her when she told me
this i completely lost my [__]
yeah dude she's playing you and mesh's
the guy
only for him to say i'll fly you and
your girlfriend out
then we'll kick your ass and double team
your girl then i'll kick your ass and
double team your girlfriend
i completely lost my cool with the guy
guys and my girlfriend for putting up
with this [__]
putting me in a situation where i have
to deal with this yeah dude this chick
is just [__] ridiculous
there's tons of other red flags dude
that's the biggest
the fact that she's doing this to you
she's a garbage human being
she's i can't i won't even say garbage
at this point she's just super young and
maybe
she needs some [__] therapy if she's
in her 30s she's a garbage human being
anyway this come on ed
you need to go back to the house and get
keys
all right hang on a second oh it's the
lovely mia everybody
hang on hang on hang on hang on
i'm in the middle of answering one of
the easiest questions ever
this guy's in a relationship are you a
jerk
yes yes i am a jerk no this she's this
guy guy's in a relationship with this
chick
and she has all these guys like texting
her all the time saying i want to [__]
you i don't care if you have
a boyfriend i'll fly you out and then
she shows them to him
oh [__] bye yes oh [__] bye did you hear
that
that's exactly what i said uh
we're long distance so maybe this is why
some of
oh we're long distance relationships so
maybe this is why some of these problems
occur i'm not sure
i do love this girl and i just am
starting to think this isn't worth the
drama and hassle anymore
would love some advice what you would do
in my shoes thanks and go [__] yourself
he's 20 years old
dude this is the easiest ever kick it to
the curb what say you nia
yeah i think so is this one of these
well this is why you need to move to my
city because if you don't
there's all these guys here like is that
what this is about this is some kind of
manipulation thing or this is just to
make you jealous is this to sort of
keep you on your toes either way it's a
mess
well if you have to ask any of those
questions it's time to leave
definitely definitely are you almost
done yes i am almost done
you know i i got in some good ones on
you last week
yeah i know you know people tweet me and
tell me that like you're talking [__]
about me like i can't believe what bill
said i can't wait for nia's response
and you know what that's not fair
because i don't even have a chance to
defend myself you just come on here
you talk [__] i'm a part of the podcast
sometimes
you know what i mean and you're not even
gonna give me the opportunity to like be
a part of the discussion you're just
gonna talk [__] about me
maybe this is how i get you on the
podcast now i talk [__]
you could just ask me
well you got you're always busy with the
kids i know if i talk [__]
you think do you think i don't know
these [__] rats are gonna [__]
tech tweets
of course they are and here you are and
here you are on the podcast
you [__] walked right into the trap
so what did you say about me
i'm trying to remember what i was what
i'm trying to remember what we were
arguing about
try to remember no you could you have a
better memory than me what was it
because i think i was right too
boxes or something stupid oh when i
became box boy
oh god here we go yeah box boy
yeah defend yourself against what
exactly
you don't already box open
that microphone in my face but defend
yourself like you're some sort of gotcha
reporter on the street
is there any truth to the rumors that
you wouldn't cut up boxes
forcing your husband hollywood golden
boy bill bird to cut them up and throw
them away for you
the [__] is this yeah you gotta cut up
some boxes sometimes
i have i have other [__] that i'm doing
oh do
you oh yes i do and i don't always get
to that what i don't have other [__]
sue me sue me
i don't have other [__] that i'm doing
we both have [__] that we're doing
i just don't i have [__] that i'm doing
and when i open a box i [__] cut it
up
i just don't think that it's productive
to pick at each other about the petty
things
okay i think this is a petty thing so my
things are petty you're
trying to make me out to be like some
sort of inconsiderate person and i don't
appreciate it did you say meow or me out
meow yeah getting sassy me out to be
sometime like this you know some sort of
attack on my character
by going on and on about the boxes this
is an election year
uh-huh or it was i'll attack your
character all i want
well you know what nia it's not that you
don't cut up the boxes
it's the way you just [__] throw them
you know or stash them i don't throw i
don't like open a box
just throw it across the floor that's
what it looks like when i walk in there
like you handle this [__]
well it's not that and you're such a
[__] everything that anyone does is
automatically against you
you take [__] way too personal like i'm
just expecting you to take care what do
you mean
everything that everyone does does the
deuce
you're the only one i'm talking to stop
trying to drag invisible people into
this [__]
you're sitting here trying to make it
seem like i'm trying to get you just
like you just take care of it you're the
box boy
when it's like i'm just being careless
in the moment because i'm trying to all
right let me open this [__] it's usually
for the kids let me put it away careless
in the moment means
most of the times you cut up the boxes
you're you're you
you don't cut up boxes i do and you can
ask my mother who watches me cut them up
all the time
ask her tomorrow and see what she says
about me cutting up boxes ask her
okay why are you acting like you're
scaring me i'm not i'm just telling you
what it is and you need to take stop
taking this [__] so personally
like i'm trying to come after you or
make you my servant you always do that
anytime i ask you to do something
anytime you have to step in and do
something you're like why do i always
do it right that is a big
heaping pile of [__] what is it
because you're like i'm aaron boy i'm
box boy
what do i work for you it's just like
everything after 900 [__] days
and you keep going like i was gonna do
it
i was gonna do it you need to go on the
road because like
i need to go on the road you took it to
there yes you [__] love me you
[__]
and you're the only [__] broad out
there that i cut up i cut up your
[__] goddamn
trash we've been around each other too
much this pandemic is getting to us baby
that's [__] you really think i'm
like treating you like aaron boy just
because i don't
cut up boxes no the way i have a temper
i have to learn to accept the fact that
when you
make a sandwich you're so
focused on making the [__] sandwich
that i'm gonna walk out there two hours
later
after you did and the mayonnaise jar is
gonna be open with the top off
the ketchup's gonna be over there
there's gonna be a bunch of crumbs it
looks like a [__] eight-year-old made
it
you are totally i am not let's talk
about the fact how many
i am not how many glasses of water are
around the house
at any given time how many half cut
lemons watch this
watch this no no you don't interrupt me
now how many half cut lemons
and half cup tomatoes are just littered
on the [__] countertop how many
hoodies and hats
are strewn about all over the house i
don't say anything cause it's not that
big a [__] deal okay
all right now watch this federal case
watch this and then you want to shut up
i'm not
watching anything listen to me oh my god
go on your goddamn podcast
and trash me those people love me that
listen
to this podcast you would never turn
against me
okay wait a minute okay
watch this that [__] about the glasses
you're 100
right i need to work on that and i'm
going to do better with the lemons and
the tomatoes
same thing with my hoodies why is it so
[__] hard for you to do that
all right fine you're right about that
fellas that is the way it's done i will
do better
people say it again i will do better
thank you you know what's actually i
really have to admit to though
and it's gonna make my whole argument my
whole craziness just really seem like
i'm nuts
but after that last argument we had
about boxes
i started to walk upstairs and i saw a
box that i just left on the chair after
i opened something and i was like
god damn it
i'm not asking you to be perfect i just
i just want an attempt that's all
i'm a mess okay i know i'm a [__]
pain in the ass to live with
just every once in a while if you could
just [__] acknowledge one of my
[__] complaints without dragging up
everything else that i've done for the
last two [__] decades you've been
with me if you could just do that if we
could just remain in the moment
that's all all right fine there you go
okay great
see we're friends we're good see people
that's how you have a productive
argument
at some point you gotta yell shout out
oh i appreciate that oh come on it was
funny that was an off them
off the mic yelling doesn't come all
right that's the podcast go
[__] yourselves congratulations to the
kansas city chiefs the tampa bay
buccaneers
uh buffalo bills an unbelievable season
for where you guys have been you guys
are
you're going to be there again it's
going to be great watching you try and
topple
the new beasts of the afc the kansas
city chiefs
uh my condolences to green bay packer
fans i know uh
i mean you guys are the yankees of
[__] football so you guys this isn't
something you're building towards this
is something you guys have always been
doing so i know that was a bitter pill
but that's it you know what your
milwaukee bucks keep beating my celtics
so there's that
all right that's it go [__] yourselves
and i'll check in on you
on thursday